[Music]
no
my
[Music]
we still have to pay attention to the
planet and the environment all that because
before it was a lot about
pesticides and today there
are a lot of people who rest the  ski
to question themselves but there are
still farmers who
do not want to change their method,
while on the other hand there are others who
really want to change and they change
but make decisions you have to
show them the evidence that we can produce
otherwise I think it's going to be quite
difficult because we have a
fairly high yield potential to feed
the population we will have to find other
methods to be able to always have the
same yield and respect
the environment and the planet
[Music]
reduction of  phyto it is beneficial
for the farmer because he is less
in contact with products that can
be dangerous for him but it is
also beneficial behind these
animals that go v  have no killer and its
customers to consume is the last
link in the chain it is the
consumer he can find himself
seeing that who has healthy agriculture
that is produced locally with as
little time as possible
[Music]
we encourage the students to  to produce
differently, that is to say to show them
that we can make a living with it without
using multitude of chemical products
multitude
of veterinary products and six in a row
[Music]
and rather organic style after I
am experimenting because  my father is
executable and I have neighbors who
use a lot of pesticides more like
to be more careful and I know
that we can produce intentions all
that I will try to reduce the use
of all his products to see a
food  better quality li
preserving our our environment
our planet for future
[Music]